في باريس
الحلقة 30
سنوات ولكن هذا الجوقة سيد الذي يضحك
كل زوجته صوفي سين في باريس
في الربيع على أسطح المنازل
دوارات الطقس بما في ذلك الأموال المخصصة للمسار البيئي
مع الفاتح الذي يصنع
اختلاف
لا مبالاة من قبل chabanois هي تفعل
على غرار حجم الإنسان فالير وحده
الله مثل المدينة جامي للسيارات
لاو ح في mpt محدودة القضية مع
إطلاق قماش برناما البحري
بواسطة طبيب نفساني في لافال في الليل
مثل الشتاء التحول في صعب هذا جيد
اللعبة التي رتبت سريرها بالقرب من العش
المسرح ومن ينزل عند الظهيرة
أيام الأسبوع في أقصى الحدود
جوليا التسمية واحد ركوب هو الحب
في بالي
المهمة n o في الصين لطلاب in
صلاح هناك دائما سيارات الأجرة في مارلو
من يتهمك بالاحتيال يتعلم
وقوف السيارات لا يزال هناك حافة
سيارات الأجرة إلى الرأس ونرى أي شخص
من يدين بالباب على الرغم من المتق السابق
كان هناك منذ الصباح في مقهى إيلي
يخصص بشكل مثالي Jourda Vert و
بناء لدينا حياة قاسية وروما
الفائز في دبي
الفتيات كاتربيلر هي مثلهم
التسول kiruna القناة هو في حد ذاته رونالد
ابنة عائشة السيد بن علي بن سعد إيزابيل
سوف يقوم تشارست بالتنسيق بين هيرات
غرب إيفا بيريس العقعق ولكن الواحد
من الأمس حيث تنام هي صديقتنا
تمسك بهذا ليس الفول السوداني بلدي
يتفوق على الاسمي بورجيه هل يقود
موسيل لا كان في يفيتوت رضوان التوزاني
الخبر هو حبك وكرهك لك
قد يقترن مع الشاي الأسود كما لو كانوا
لا تعيش ربع تشغيل weah لأن
الصيغ mirandès auguste perret le
كينار حيث شهد العدو تجربة ممتازة
بالإضافة إلى جعل القمر راهب حبيبيها
ليلة لو كوربوزييه كانايين وماسا إن
ribéry sur le kadima بواسطة download me I'm
outta هنا وأنا acc aha
ناسا لن يكون لها بيت دعارة غريب
حبيبي جزيرة السماء بلدي رمز
لتحسين اللمسات الصغيرة
جوانب الحرب غير المعروفة لهم
يطلق
فليني الفني ouakam si owen wilson
الذهب إلى yoann الذي يتوج دي سان باولو
لكن البقعة صنعت التيتانيوم وأكسدتها
الكربون يكون جيمس خليج لطيف ونبيل ولكن
كما هو متوقع يأخذ الجميع
ارييل اتياس دولت ابادي في توبا 10pro
Vitaly اللمسات حافلة لفة ولكن محظورة
لكنها في الرودون أنت جميلة للأسف
الخرائط حيث يوجد دائمًا أفضل طراز estelle
أكيرا جميلة ولكن يجب أن يقال عبثا
أنه في ليل بيا يكون في الفصل الدراسي 6 أشهر
مش عبده مخزني لا العدسة
ماتينس فنلندا 6 حالات الشتاء الألغام
مثل النجم الساقط في نيويورك حيث
ضرر lissouba الدايت بيري sfi
نوفمبر انها فتاة سوداء bastarache ل
يأمل رامي الفتيل Loisel bourges
المدرسة التي ستعيد إلى بادا هي مدرسة جدا
سرعان ما قال المحلل عماد الرقم
موسى دور في tv one at l Famous at
تغلب على كل أم
تيلي تفعل لا مادلين الذي وضع علامة
بادا بورجي فون أو واغنر
montparnasse obama syrian malama لكن
إطلاق مثل هذا البيع غير المحبوب
لا لماما سيمون دي بوفوار
كاتالا أو المجاعة في البيك تجذب و
قد مرت
فتاة تدرك هذا القارب رواتبنا نحن
التصرف بمفردك وكولين مينارد الأرض هناك
كين إلى حقائب البلديات من الأمونيوم
مناج الإسلاميون بملف المشاعر في ستة
أمتار
فتاة فرنسية سبتمبر هالفين يوان فا
إرفاق اللجوء أثناء ألمانيا
أو كادوا يقتلونها ووزير سابق و
توالت لي صديق نيكام في كان هل عليه
المياه على المستعمرات طويلة
benatia themine rage korean mecheri
في قلعة نوميا الحمراء لقد عشت أو
استئناف الحياة قال ابراهيم لارا ستون
دون أن يقول أين يعيش في ti مثل tafer aux
كاذبة لأن لفات لكنهم هم نحن
اي فون في ديركو سيكون لدينا
سيارة الأخبار تاريخ فووسبالل برات
والجيوش المخلصين على المدى القصير أمس و
wario و أخيرا أماني و
فتاة البند من اختيار edmee و brl أو
شفرات وهي تعمل بشكل أفضل في الصين
في الواقع تجاه ساو باولو سوف تضطر إلى ذلك
داليان سيكريتن تشوي جي سونغ مارولا
رستو يوسع بيما بن طلال للثور
سلسلة كروتون أ إنها قبة ماساكي
انخفاض القطط المريضة aoma tryba
لدينا الكثير من الهواة والشيا
لتحمل تدفق كبير من المطر الأزرق
انتهى حمادي جانا بشكل سيء عند اختيار fne
ghislaine أقل هدوءًا يجعل الأمر
واتارا لرئاسة نبيل عربي ل
يؤلم هذا العام لمواجهة فالا كثيرا
بالتأكيد قال يوم الاثنين في فيلم ATS التفاعلي
وفي الولاية
على الرغم من inaya في الترامبولين الزلزال
Halil Berktay في تشطيب لينو فيدا ديس
فساتين أو لا شيء "مشاهد الحرب علي
رفض جلب فاتن لن يكون لديه
نقول أن أنطوان موسيني في طولون
مانهاتن الجديدة والعطريات عبدالله
كروك بشابي عدى بن حمان
إنه يشبه لولا لكنهم جميعًا مجانين
سوداتل ولكن تشافي التقليدية باب
مشهابي في دير الرهالب في الرجل
ليون سيحاول نيكولا الساخنة
ساعده في أضنة كنت أغادر بن نجمة
غرق المباراة قال آلان رييل
فريق التجمع في الفهد بجدة مرحبا و
شكرا لوجودك معنا مرحبا يوما
شابان دي سيلاك بالكاد من قبل
للحديث عن مشاريعه ، يجب أن نتذكر
أن مكان النجم هو فقط
مصطلح من منظور كان
مصمم أو القرن السابع عشر من قبل بلدنا
أندريه لنا البستاني لويس الرابع عشر
من قلعة التويلري
ذهب الآن ولفترة طويلة
وكان الشانزليزيه مجرد زقاق
مشجرة وهي فقط في نهاية الثامن عشر
القرن الذي كان يعتقد أنه بمناسبة
نهاية هذا المنظور لنصب تذكاري
ثم ظهرت فكرة أصلية إلى حد ما
كان الأمر يتعلق ببناء فيل
عملاق مزرق قليلاً من البقية مع
الحلي الذهبية التي بداخلها
تم وضعها
غرف معيشة مختلفة من غرف المعيشة
حتى الشاي واختيار الفيل
لم يكن بريئا لأنه
مما كانت عليه في العصور القديمة
كان الفيل رمزًا للمتانة
من الصلابة ولكن أيضًا رمز
المجد العسكري وبعد ذلك إذا
يتبنى بونابرت فكرة الفيل
ولكن ليس للنجم بل إلى
الباستيل المعاكس باريس لأنه
التي حددها هو نفسه مع عظيم
رئيس
هانيبال مثل حنبعل كان عنده
عبرت جبال الألب وشيء معين
طريقة تكريمه لحنيبال
الذي عبرهم على ظهره
الغاء حالة الفيل الصوت من العياط
مثل دفاع مكان المصري
في الواقع الدفاع ليس أكثر ولا
أقل من ذروة
المنظور الذي كنا نتحدث عنه سابقًا
بالساعة التي سبقت أوتو فون بوقت طويل
jeinsen كان مبنى ضخمًا
القوس الذي هو استجابة لقوس
انتصار النجم ولكن أيضا لذلك
من الرف الدائري تم اعتباره كليًا
الكثير من البنية التحتية منذ أن كان لدينا
قررت أن تجعل الدفاع
مانهاتن الباريسية وفي الستينيات
في أوائل الستينيات كان هناك مشروع
دو تور لوحة الأخوين أندريه جان
كان بولاك مهندسًا معماريًا قام بتصميمه
برج عملاق بطول 750 متر
من الارتفاع الذي هو في ذلك الوقت
ضخمة للغاية وسبعة أبراج
هدفين من ناحية
بمثابة تتابع القمر الصناعي و ذلك
يجب أن تغطي الاحتياجات
في التلفزيون في إعادة الإرسال على أ
نصف قطرها 250 كم ولكن قبل كل شيء كان لا بد من ذلك
أيضا بمثابة بنية تحتية
مطعم سياحي ضخم
بانورامي ليكون موجودا تقريبا
على ارتفاع 600 متر يجب أن يكون هناك
الفنادق الكبيرة مثل الأشياء
أن هذا المشروع في الواقع لم ير النور
لأسباب تكنولوجية
لأنه مع تطور
الأقمار الصناعية نظام الترحيل
تحيز إعادة الإرسال التلفزيوني
لم تعد هناك حاجة إلى الأرض لتكون و
كمشروع هذا البرج
كان قيد الإعداد ، أدركنا أن
عدم الجدوى وفجأة لم نر
يوم
يذهب إلى كندا لكنها شحدتني إذا
سواء كانت تقبل مرض الكاميرا أم لا
نحن أيضا vahirua منارات والجدران ل
الكرة ومن الصعب القول
لذلك كان هناك مشروعان
الإسراف في باريس أخيرا يمكننا
أذكر على سبيل المثال ذلك من aero Paris الذي
صممه المهندس المعماري أندريه
lurçat في العشرينات من القرن العشرين
القرن والذي يتكون من تركيب أ
مهبط الطائرة على الممر
من الواضح إذن أن هذا البجع
مهبط الطائرات سيكون
برفقة مجموعة كاملة
البنية التحتية ، الطائرات يجري
مخزنة في القبو كما في الباب
الطائرات على المدرج من قبل
مجموعة كاملة من المصاعد ونفس الشيء
طريقة نقل السيارات
بواسطة جسور المشاة قد أودعت
الركاب الذين كانوا سيأخذون طائراتهم
وأقلعت الطائرات بالكامل
قلب باريس
اليوم يمكننا بالتأكيد
تصور فكرة
نفس الشيء ولكن هناك أفكار من هذا القبيل
كان لديه المئات في باريس وهناك
طالما شعرت باريس أ
دعوة عالمية
ما هو صحيح سنقوله في نهاية
القرن السابع عشر حتى حرب 14 أو
باريس بعيدة قليلاً عن الغرب
رؤية منارة العالم التي هي الحياة
المرجع من لحظة أ
المدينة تفقد قليلا هذا النوع من الدوحة
عالمي يثير أقل من ذلك بكثير
حيوية المهندسين المعماريين و
مخططي المدينة
إنها تشبه إلى حد ما باريس اليوم
لم يعد لدى باريس الشعور بكونها
منارة العالم ولم يعد لديك
الشعور بكونك منارة العالم
باريس لم تعد تولد هذين
مشاريع الآثار الباهظة
باهظ
السيد الساخن عرض كامل الجاز عليه
سبب الحيوان في مباراة الشكر وفي
أراك مرة أخرى شكرا أراك قريبا جدا
تغيير الإيقاعات
إلى الشانزليزيه
في الشمس تحت المطر من الظهر حتى منتصف الليل
هناك كل ما تريد
الشانزليزيه ميمون سيحضره
صوت الشانزليزيه مثل صوتنا
انتهى بهم المطاف في فندقهم الميت لكن المكوك
إلى الشانزليزيه
في الشمس تحت المطر ظهرا
في منتصف الليل كل ما عليك
نريد إليزيه الأبطال